we're told this is the graph of y is
equal to three-halves to the X and
that's it right over there use the graph
to find an approximate solution to
three-halves to the x is equal to five
so pause this video and try to do this
on your own before we work on this
together all right now let's let's work
on this
so they already give us a hint of how to
solve it they have the graph of y is
equal to three after the X they graph it
right over here and this gives us a hint
and especially because it's they want us
to find an approximate solution that
maybe we can solve this equation or
approximate a solution this equation
through graphing and the way we can do
that is we could take each side of this
equation and set them up as a function
we could set y equals to each side of it
so if we set y equals to the left-hand
side we get Y is equal to three has to
the X power which is what they
originally give us the graph of that and
if we set y equal to the right hand side
we get Y is equal to five and we can
graph that and what's interesting here
is if we can find the x value that gives
us the same that Y value on both of
these equations well that means that
those graphs are going to intersect and
if I'm getting the same Y value for that
x value in both of these well then that
means that 3 has to the X is going to be
equal to 5 and so we can look at where
they intersect and get an approximate
sense of what x value that is and we can
see it at least over here it looks like
X is roughly equal to 4 so X is
approximately equal to 4 and if we
wanted to and we'd be done at that point
if you wanted to you could try to test
it out you could say hey does that
actually work out three-halves to the
fourth power is that equal to 5 let's
see 3 to the fourth is 81 2 to the
fourth is 16 it gets us it gets us
pretty close to 5 16 times 5 is 80 so
it's not exact but it gets us pretty
close and if you had a graphing
calculator that could really zoom in and
zoom in and zoom in you would get
a value you would see that X is slightly
different than X equals four but let's
do another example the key here is that
we can approximate solutions to
equations through graphing so here we
are told this is the graph of y is equal
to so we have this third degree
polynomial right over here use the graph
to answer the following questions how
many solutions does the equation X to
the third minus 2x squared minus X plus
1 equals negative 1/2 pause this video
and try to think about that when we
think about solutions to this we could
say all right well let's imagine two
functions one is y is equal to X to the
third minus 2x squared minus X plus 1
which we already have graphed here and
let's say that the other equation or the
other function is y is equal to negative
1 and then how many times do these
intersect that would tell us how many
solutions we have so that is y is equal
to negative 1 and so every time they
intersect that means we have a solution
to our original equation and they
intersect 1 2 & 3 times so this has
three solutions what about the second
situation how many solutions does the
equation all of this business equal to
have well same drill we could set y
equals 2x to the 3rd minus 2x squared
minus X plus 1 and then we could think
about another function what if Y is
equal to 2 well y equals 2 would be up
over there y equals 2 and we could see
it only intersects y equals all of this
business once so this is only going to
have one solution so the key here and
I'll just write it out and these are
screenshots from the exercise on Khan
Academy where you'd have to type in 1 or
in the previous example you would type
in 4 but these are examples where you
can take an equation of one variable set
both sides of them independently equal
to Y graph them and then think about
where they intersect because the X
values where they intersect will be
solutions to your original equation and
a graph is a useful way of approximating
what a solution will be especially if
you have a graphing calculator or desmos
or something like that